[Music]
for a while it seemed like the
ambulances were the only vehicles
passing through on their way to
Lombardi's red zone and all the area's
towns under quarantine just a few
kilometers from the center of Italy's
coronavirus outbreak the security
personnel often outnumbered the cars on
the road at this checkpoint no one could
get in or out without permission on ket
sharin luckily I've been stopping a lot
of people and this makes me feel anxious
because even if the center the virus
isn't right here it's not that far away
Bruno's friend Luigi also lives in
ceresco in a part of the town that
hadn't yet been locked down the fuel may
throw me know the problem is not just a
few meters in the red zone or not in the
red zone the issue concerns the whole of
Lombardi not living in the red zone is
not that much of an advantage I can move
but the danger is everywhere it was just
a short while later that the threat
level was indeed reassessed and the
boundary enlarged the sense of alarm
here is only growing we've seen many
ambulances go in and out of the
quarantined area these past few hours
and in the last 30 minutes we've had to
move about a kilometer down the road
after authorities decided to expand the
red zone in Rome an emergency meeting
was held to deal with the crisis as
Italy's health minister and several of
his European counterparts came together
in an effort to find solutions
non-chinese una modify cabinet is no
change for travel conditions of Italians
traveling from Italy going abroad this
is the first commitment made by
countries bordering with Italy they
wanted to share the idea that blocking
borders would be a mistake a
disproportionate and wrong measure but
in and around the exclusion zone
residents concerned themselves with
other borders these newly created ones
inside northern Italy as streets that
would usually be full sat nearly empty
and a growing number of people worried
about the effectiveness of their
government's current containment
measures mohammed abdullah al jazeera in
the town of joy Lesko in northern italy